hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new apple watch series
six and today we're gonna be comparing
it to my series five
there are a lot of similarities but
there also are some different so we're
gonna point out all of those to you guys
a couple things i'm really excited about
testing out such as the brightness
difference and the always on display
but let's go ahead and jump right into
it and get this
opened up i did get the one that has
the new red color so that's one of the
differences we have new color options
there's also a blue
and then there's a titanium a dark one
as you guys could see
right here it's always really cool to
see how it's clean on the outside and
they add color
and some design elements on the inside i
did order the new braided solo loop
in charcoal and fedex is supposed to
deliver today with the watch but it's
not here
so i'm excited to check that out and i'm
going to do a little review video on
that so make sure you guys are
subscribed
let's pop this open so it does come with
a charging cable
but we do not have a power brick which
is why
this is so slim now here's something
very interesting for you guys
i have my previous apple watch boxes
and apple has made a lot of changes over
the years
so let me grab my series 5 which is
right there
it's the same width but you guys can see
how much slimmer the new one is because
they're not including that usb
charger you guys let me know what do you
think about that
and this is my original apple watch this
is the cheap version back there
look how much bigger this is and the box
is just so much nicer from before
even with the cheap sport models they
also gave us this nice
plastic hard case and then you open that
up and there's a soft material over here
and then like the whole box on the
inside that holds everything is just way
heavier and nicer
it's kind of a shame that now if you're
buying a more expensive watch
the packaging is just a lot worse
they're just trying to cut costs that's
my opinion
let's go ahead and take it out here
let's
pop this and i love red it's my favorite
color
so i'm excited to see this red one i've
bought gold the last few years
come on this thing is cardboard now or
paper instead of being a soft material
like my other ones so here we have it
it looks nice looks like a nice aluminum
red i also pulled the straps out here
this is very interesting the straps
don't look as
deep and rich of a red as i expect they
don't really match
up to the watch i'm guessing this is
probably on purpose
but it's a little too light for my
liking i mean obviously it's not
pink but it's closer on the pinker side
than i would
want so i can't wait to get that
charcoal braided lube in
let's jump into comparing the exteriors
and both of these are 44 millimeter
models
so it's interesting that my previous
gold series 5 stainless steel just looks
a little bit more substantial i think
that's probably because of the
reflections
um from the coating on here and then the
band the milanese loop
also comes out a little bit with with
the steel
instead of just you know being recessed
in there so it looks a little bit larger
looks nicer of course than the aluminum
but other than that the top and the
front
looks identical the crowns look the same
and as far as thickness
they look identical as well now let's go
ahead and flip these over to the bottom
let me clean these off here really quick
and by the way you can pick up one of
these
max tech super soft nice shirts and then
work shelf down below or a mask or a
hoodie
let's flip these over uh yeah so the
sensors are
definitely different the series five
looks like it has one light in the
center and then sensors around
whereas the series six has four lights
all around
and then we have four circular sensors
and that's because the series 6 has
those
extra features that we'll talk about in
just a bit now before we test out those
new sensors
let's compare the displays so right here
i have
one of the new watch faces and i want to
let you guys know that all the new watch
faces are available on the series 5
and the series 4 so that's not a reason
to
upgrade now as far as the screens they
are identical the same exact size
the corners around it the same as you
guys could see right here
now as far as the brightness of the
screen some people have been saying that
the new one is brighter
but it's not supposed to be brighter in
the regular mode the peak brightness is
actually
the same it's the always-on mode we're
gonna test out a series of different
watch faces
to see how that affects it i have both
these set to the maximum brightness we
adjusted that top camera
for the displays not the table and let's
do our first
test there we go and
what do you see vadim look at the camera
looks the same to me
yeah i am not seeing any difference in
brightness with the always on mode
that's very interesting
the settings are maxed out there's no
extra setting that i found
let's try one of the new ones here so
here we go
they look the same and
they look the same they look the same uh
so
it does actually have an ambient sensor
on the apple watch so let's pull out my
phone here
grab the flashlight and see if that
makes any difference for us i don't know
where the sensor is
it's brighter but not by that much
you guys can see from above i can see
the outline better
yeah i mean there's also better contrast
which helps yeah
it is brighter for sure here we have
another new one this is the count
up one for people that i think they said
racing right
um let's go like this honestly hearing
two and a half times more i was
expecting a drastic difference and that
was
probably my biggest complaint about the
series five is that the always-on mode
was not bright enough let me try the
gradient one this is one that i liked
with my stainless steel for the gold
color
but it just wasn't bright enough for me
to use it consistently
do that it's a little brighter
it's a little bit brighter throw some
light on here okay both of my seat got
brighter
i gotta be honest with you i'm a little
bit disappointed by that
let's try out this chronograph pro i
think that's actually the racing one
let's go ahead and do or maybe that's a
diving one i don't know
once again the result looks very similar
at least to my eyes
and just to double check for myself and
to prove to you guys that in the
settings
there's no additional option for
brightness during always on we just have
one setting here the always-on mode is
on and both of them are
maxed out so that is definitely a bummer
but
on the plus side one thing that i didn't
expect as i was going through
adding these watch faces you guys see
sometimes there's just a little bit of
stuttering
where this one is perfectly smooth so
there definitely is a difference in
performance
with the new chip here now let's get
back into the sensors
and there are a ton of different
similarities between them along with
some of the features
so before i show you guys the actual
differences and we test those out
we actually wrote a list of similarities
so
both of them have the same second gen
heart sensors there's the same compass
the same
accelerometer the same fall detection
the same exact
50 meters of water resistance same 32
gigabytes of storage
same ceramic and sapphire glass same
speaker phone
same microphone same noise app support
the same w3 chip and the same exact
bluetooth five so a lot of the features
are identical
now we do have the differences now so we
have new wi-fi
five support for the series six instead
of just 2.4 gigahertz
it will do five gigahertz and for me
that was never
an issue but i did notice some people
complain about it taking too long to put
music on there
so that could be a benefit to you and
then we off the always-on altimeter so
if you're somebody that hikes
you can use that function along with
that there's another hardware difference
inside and that's that the new series 6
has the u1 chip the same as in the new
iphones
and that means in the future your phone
will be able to track your watch
and potentially if it's hidden behind a
wall or under couch cushion
it's gonna be really easy to find it so
that is a nice
feature now probably the biggest one
that they cared about on screen
was the new blood oxygen sensor so we
are gonna go ahead and test that out
it is showing me don't have it too close
up which is fine it's right here
don't want it too tight but you want it
snug i'm facing up relaxed
just exactly like i'm doing now i don't
know how much this matters for a lot of
people
for me i'm usually good but if you're
somebody with allergies or health
conditions
this could definitely be a reason to
upgrade to the new one
looks like i'm at 96 once i removed my
watch and put this in the right spot
so that is pretty good and that could
definitely be handy as i mentioned
so with all of that said who should
upgrade from a series 5
to a series 6 and if you're buying one
should you buy series 6 or should you
try to get a discounted series 5.
i saw some great deals on amazon we'll
link them down
below for you to check out first off if
that new blood oxygen sensor is very
convenient to you
i think that's probably gonna be the
biggest reason to upgrade the display
brightness
that didn't show up that much the
altimeter i don't think that matters
that much as well unless you really
constantly need to know what your
altitude is
and another reason to upgrade for some
people are going to be the colors
we have that blue we have this red
there's some actual titanium edition
models as well
so those are going to be appealing to
some people i personally am a big fan
of red but one big disappointment is
that
if you're buying this product red model
you have to get a red
band this standard sport band i really
don't like the color of it i'm going to
be taking this off
right away now the braided solo loop
that is a deeper red i like how that
looks much
better but you can't change out any
other ones you have to get a red
band so i ordered the charcoal braided
solo loop
and if you're ordering separate it costs
a hundred bucks
instead of 50 getting it together so
that's a bummer because if you get say
the blue one you can choose any band you
want with it you can save the money
if you want to go with something else so
it sucks that they're limiting you
there now if you're looking to buy one
instead of
upgrade should you buy the series 6 or
should you get a discounted series 5.
personally as long as you don't need the
blood oxygen as long as you don't want
one of these new colors
i would say go for the series 5. there's
just way too many similarities and the
display brightness as far as we could
see
wasn't really that noticeable so i would
save the money
and go for a series 5 instead once again
there's links down in the video
description
below thank you guys for watching click
that circle above to subscribe for our
full review
the review of that new solo braided loop
watch band when i get that one
in and some other comparisons has been
max and i'll see you in the next video